this is a deserted island hey no it's
not we're here oh yeah do you guys know
why I brought you on this island no no
there's a timer right there with 25
minutes where for the next 25 minutes
you cannot attack each other okay at all
and you have 24 minutes and 45 seconds
to gather material make armor make
weapons and everything and when the time
is up the last man standing wins $10,000
oh that's a big number
yes Carl you can finally buy that card
Chandler you could just have money for
work Chris stop winning so much okay I'm
sorry
let's go Carl I put a chest here with
goodies in it for you Chris
I put a chest over there with goodies in
it Chandler I've baited chest full of
goodies for you as well you you gotta go
get the other chest Carl your chest is
right here yeah there you go you're
gonna build a base why would I not
should you go find diamonds or something
nah do me mine yeah yeah sweetie can I
get some torches you can craft torches
oh no I can't actually because I've
nobody really are you gonna you get a
bit elaborate oh yeah I mean no not oh
yeah sorry I didn't I didn't mean that
you guys will have to duke it out on
this deserted island can't we just be
friends I mean sure but then I'll just
keep the 10 grand everybody I hate all
of you
oh wait did you have your mom's house oh
my gosh she found a lot of diamond let's
go
he'll have these with me Chandler Oh
what fool you ruined my chances last
game I'm not letting you do i chance yes
thank you for complying I'm gonna help
Chandler strip mine because Chandler is
Chandler what Oh lapis let's go
enchant table coming I'm gonna hold down
in my bunker down here and I want to
place some traps with redstone I have a
new shroud which is crack oh nothing my
shred is I don't think I'm gonna find
time and so I'm gonna try to build
good castle we're just gonna strip-mine
we're gonna try and get as many
resources as we can we might not get
diamonds but that's not the end of the
world if we just get a bunch of iron
Jimmy I need aqua infinity immediately
you gave my speed and slow it yeah I'm
in an underground water cave Oh
skeletons in here come here
alright now that we've got redstone
we're gonna set some traps I found
something that nobody has ever found in
this game girlfriend
what evidence there is that humans are
smarter than cats none well actually
humans don't get scared by vacuum
cleaners that all right so this is
Chris's Hill Hey hey Horace Hill boom
this is Chandler's Hill boom bow you
guys still have ten minutes left until
you're gonna PvP for $10,000 oh yeah
going down especially Chris yeah Chris
wait are you two thinking of teaming
Chris whoa why would you do that we're
not thinking of anything just kind of
doing it while you guys finish building
your bases I'm gonna flood the island
with magma cubes oh okay okay I mean
just do you I guess look at the bottom
of Karl's tower it's making it laugh
looks like a demon island now how about
we spice it up a little bit yes please
keep spicing it and more ocelots please
Chandler died good
that doesn't count jelly don't pick up
your stuff tried to jump off into the
water and I miss wait stop here's your
chambers
yes all right you guys have five minutes
I'm getting my stuff oh my pants where
my pants I just saw a lot of ocelots all
over the place they're like everywhere
and I Wow Chris you left a hole in it
that was uncalled for
oh wow Chris why would you do that did
you make a hole why did you get creepers
why'd you get a base full of creepers
you may go home now I can make a whole
dress why didn't you wait what oh is
this because you need a car
bad you have to get a base full of
creepers no speaking an arena you were
gonna block the floor under us and then
we would all blow up I see what you're
doing here okay boys are you ready yes
to fight on this island
yes but nervous this is a 10-grand fight
now here's here's the deal with this
fight Carl I'm dead yeah yeah yeah what
is Chandler to do to get out of it
alright here's here's the deal boys Carl
go on top of your tower or curse is
inside of my tower right now what is he
doing no do you think oh do you think
you guys can now officially attack each
other ready for that the thing is he
landed onto my trap Carl I can't believe
I pushed myself onto your job we just
don't want us to have content Carl you
literally didn't put up a fight I saw it
looks like you just jumped on to gee
that's $10,000 mean nothing to you
wanted so desperately look at him just
sniping in his little little Tower know
what Carl you got out so fast I want to
give you a second chance
really yeah go back over there get on
your setup mostly because I need content
I mean if you just want to camp there I
mean I guess I could just go to my base
in camp - yeah I don't care if this
takes a year whoever is the last man
standing
all right wins starting now Carl so
don't die cuz you're not getting another
life I just spawned here Chandler you
want some stuff - yeah can I have a lob
up like you know but there's 64 pieces
of TNT I'm going to go underneath
Chandler space and I'm gonna build an
entire TNT Tower you better watch out
for my trap Carl I think you and Chris
had the exact same plan I think Carl is
actually lead
a bunch of creepers I don't know how
you're gonna kill them up there but I
don't know how they're gonna kill me
they should definitely come up oh my
gosh
I've got a murder that was so set on
that magma block but it's God gosh wait
Carl you've got the build up right I
like this TNT Jimmy I don't feel
comfortable in this mouth 10 grands oh
you want to know why what happened bye
bye no the car died again okay Carl why
are you running towards the TT uet I
don't know I'm trying not to
oh my goodness what happened what did I
get hit with Taylor I think should I get
Chandler a second life to know I don't
spoil your outcome over here you
betrayed me Carl
what the heck wait what did Carla do to
him nothing Taylor just dropped you into
your car oh but actually blew up well
we're not friends so Carl you're just
gonna take over Taylor space yes okay
yeah you were bombing him but then
somehow you killed yourself this video
so far has been a mess what did you
expect we don't know what we're doing
hey I think I'm professional I just
found diamonds I think he found him in
Chandler's body I think a call cheated
it lied to me Paul
Carl I have Chandler on the phone he's
saying you backstabbed him tell Chandler
I have a closer truce with $10,000 oh
you don't trust me I'm trying to figure
out how to go back up this is I
accidentally ran into Chandler's part of
base and I don't know his face so
Chandler what are you gonna do to Carl
he's currently fighting for 10 grand
know what I'm dumping a bucket of salmon
on you
no Jimmy can you go into my base and
figure out how I can get back out Carl's
literally just sitting on top of the
tower
no I'm building and by building I mean
destroying ouch yes hey Carl here I want
to help
buddy chris has been winning a lot
here's a week I'm in Chris's base I'm
trying to find him while he's trying to
plot I'm just trying to kill immediately
Karl there's a lot on the line for this
duel you sure you just want to run right
into it he disrespected my ocelots and
for that reason he's going down ha ha ha
you guys are bad with TNT I'm so bad
what did that accomplish all right Carl
let's duel
are you so high up there do this alright
put a torch right here I didn't know
this was down here down in my bunker
come to me is he trying to blow up down
to me or blow down not know so Chris
how's your day good pretty good
Thunder is he coming down all right I'm
going with the team see now I'm coming
down Carl it it's not gonna matter why
is it not gonna matter I'm gonna win it
Norman what are you guys trying to throw
to you d down at me yeah we're literally
trying to do everything we can to help
Carl I see his trap all right this is it
the tool we've waited literally three
hours for diamond get our ten grand I
found it by killing up stop it Oh Chris
aspiring $10,000 oh he's got a diamond
sword
John he got it from chin it was mine I
wanna run Chris and give better
materials stop swinging
Oh Oh you ever had a disadvantage this
is there's so much money on the line oh
you're dead
you're trash you don't deserve it Karl
you had better diamond sword and I still
got you with my traps there was TNT
underground baby there was a little bit
of a rocker Karl you had a diamond sword
diamond armor to recharge before hitting
I didn't know what to free that oh you
didn't no wonder they are bad that guy
yeah if you're gonna be part of the mr.
B's game enchanter you got to do your
homework but no I know and next time I'm
not losing call chris has stolen a
quarter of a million dollars from you
know that and with that thank you for
watching this mr. B's gaming video I
will see you guys in the next one
hopefully Karl could eventually win some
money because he needs it